as covet cases spiral upward and new
warnings resound
people in many parts of the world find
themselves wondering if the summer
respite we'd hoped for
could come to an abrupt end all thanks
to a new
and especially adaptable strain first
identified in india it's known as the
delta variant
and is significantly more contagious
than previously thought
after completely overwhelming india's
health care system
and causing mass suffering and death the
variant has spread to more than 80
countries
vaccines should stop it from spreading
but it's a race against
time and with many countries already
returning to normalcy reimposing rules
could be difficult corona mutations how
deadly
is delta
welcome to to the point it's a pleasure
to welcome our guests
tobias court is an epidemiologist from
the charity
in berlin and he says the best way to
counter the delta variant
is to intensify the vaccination campaign
and engage in more targeted surveillance
rather than panic mongering and it's a
pleasure to welcome benjamin alvarez
grouper he is a dw colleague from
chile and he believes the worrying
developments in chile should be a
warning sign for those who pledge to
reopen fast
as vaccination campaigns gather steam
and we're very glad to have back on the
program ankita
she is a dw correspondent based in delhi
and she is convinced we need to rely on
scientific expertise
along with rigorous safety measures if
we want to
prevent this rise of more dangerous
variants so let me begin
by asking you uh dr kurt you know
we've got sunny days here in berlin
we've got balmy evenings plummeting
infection rates
things have been looking pretty good and
now i find myself thinking
are we going back to where we were at
the end of last year
are we really seeing a dramatic
risk of another spike i know you say we
shouldn't be doing
panic mongering but how dangerous is it
well first of all we should enjoy
right now the situation and as you said
the numbers are going down so
the infection rate is is really on a
really
i wouldn't say record low but it's
really reassuring
yes the pandemic situation is not over
there is a risk that we see
a potential increase in the fall again
however we have to look in more detail
so
pcr test positive doesn't mean there's a
consequence doesn't mean that if i have
a positive test result i can spread or
give the virus to someone else we need
other information to really tell that
also you may get
mild symptoms if you vaccinate it but
may not get severe disease so we have to
look a little bit more careful
rather than saying just pcr test
positive which will go up
very likely in the fall so it depends on
the setting on the region of the country
the number of people vaccinated whether
this is a true risk or not
we should be respectful we should be on
alert to really
watch the situation closely but to
really now
think what may have happened or what
will happen in the fall i think it's
it's a little bit too early
to to be alarmed in a way that we're
having panic
let me go to ankita because yuankita
said in your statement that we need to
rely on scientific
expertise and in fact india is working
to sequence
thousands of samples at the moment so
what do we know so far about why the
delta variant is so dangerous
and whether it or new mutations like
delta
plus could elude existing vaccines
what india has done is for the this time
as compared to what happened in the last
week in april and may
they have classified the delta plus
variant as a variant of concern
so that means there is health
surveillance going on and the tracking
of you know
these cases but what uh india still
lacks is
a lot of research into why uh the delta
variant is leading to so many so much
hospitalization
and that the research is not happening
because
uh the focus has right now completely
shifted from listening to experts
uh to focusing more on um you know um
administrative stuff like you know
procuring oxygen
um you know um imposing lockdowns
because you know uh
india cannot afford to have like another
you know wave so uh that's been the
issue at that their their end but what
we need to understand is that the delta
variant
um will it will expand its you know um
will reach more people more vulnerable
populations because india's vaccination
rate is
like really low thank you very much and
we're going to come
back to that uh in just a moment but one
place where the vaccination rate
has been very high is your country
benjamin chile in fact uh
the more than 78 of the population has
now been vaccinated once
62 percent uh twice and yet a new wave
of infection is washing
over chile why what are the scientists
there saying
the scientists are saying that they
warned the politicians who took these
decisions on one side
you have chile with an incredible
vaccine campaign you just mentioned the
numbers
when we have chile where for example
israel countries who have
had a very successful and very quick
vaccine rollout
but on the other side you see
politicians taking decisions like
um lifting mobility giving people the
chance to
go from one place to another even if
they had both vaccines
having this dynamic quarantines that
mean that
if you're living in the city in one
place you can move freely and in the
other
ones you have to be isolated at home and
of course if there's a lot of mobility
even if you have a lot of
people a lot of the high percentage of
the population that have been vaccinated
they
will not be efficient and then you will
have high numbers like the ones that
we're seeing now
and chile is entering winter now so the
numbers are expected to continue
increasing strengthening and getting the
hospitals also in a really difficult
situation that they don't have
capacities and many of these intensive
care units anymore
thank you very much uh let me ask you uh
tobias court what lessons
can we learn from chile i think
many of us uh and in fact in your
opening statement you also talk about
the need to intensify the vaccination
campaign
and i think many of us thought that if
we did that
and it has intensified here in germany
now for example
that the likelihood of dangerous new
mutations would fall
yet apparently that's not the case in
chile i don't think that the likelihood
that a variant develops
is falling but the likelihood that
people get sick or spread
the virus so so that's something
different so the
development of variants will continue on
a global
level for sure as many people get
infected and as more people get infected
there will be a variant in that specific
setting which then is superior to other
variants
which does not mean that if you take
that virus and put it in another setting
that it will act in the same way
so we have to really carefully look at
the data collect the right
data carefully see how the dynamic
changes in terms of number of people
vaccinated number of people
getting sick number of people testing
positive and what it means for
the respective setting so it's important
to not just
look at one number we have to look the
uh at the totality of the dynamic
situation before we make
decisions but we have to be careful and
on alert to really not say okay
things are over and communicate that no
things are not over
things can come back but the question is
how so
from what i'm hearing we have to remain
vigilant even if we get close to that
holy grail of herd immunity
yes but herd immunity is is not a
specific number it's dynamic depending
on the likelihood that a virus spreads
this will affect
the the cutoff of the so-called herd
immunity so we have to be on alert but
without being
panicking specifically in germany on the
global level again many countries
never had the chance to get one person
vaccinated because they don't have any
vaccines available so far we come back
to that later i believe
so it's really important to understand
the situation and to have a surveillance
system that actually works and we're
looking at the right numbers
one other very quick uh follow-up
question many people in chile were
vaccinated with the chinese vaccine with
cynopharm
does the fact that infection rates are
rising uh reflect
defects uh in that vaccine no um i think
even if you vaccinated with any vaccine
you can test positive the question is
what does it mean are you really getting
sick and i'm not familiar with the
numbers in in
in chile so it's not just looking at
testing positive because that likelihood
exists even
after beyond tech or madonna or the
seneca
so so i don't think it's it's a it's a
question of quality of the vaccine that
has been given out in chile
benjamin do you want to weigh in on that
point no i agree totally and i think
what's important is not just the
vaccination but the crisis
communication to say not go into
panic and the delta variant is coming i
mean
authorities in chile say it hasn't
reached the country yet but that's
let's see it's only a matter of time
right but
it's to say the pandemic is not over
the numbers are rising and we cannot
just rely on the vaccines
to say if we vaccinate the amount of
people in the country that they
the cases will go down because that's
not the case and let's
talk a little bit more about precautions
and
uh and also take another look at travel
because of course we are now moving into
summer
and many people have been hoping to have
a semblance at least
of vacation so and
um in india the religious festival
kombela
is often blamed for having been a super
spreader in the late winter early
spring to what extent was travel
implicated
in that terrible surge that we did see
in india and have people changed their
attitudes in regard to travel
um i would say in terms of traveling
interstate
there has been a reduction uh people are
um
very actually more than aware they're
very scared uh especially with the
rising number of deaths uh but what we
need to understand
is that when public transport it's
already started opening up in plain big
cities like
bengaluru it saw like a huge surge you
know last month so
we have we see public transport opening
up and there is an uptick in public
transport and in a country
with over a billion people it's very
difficult to
socially distance so it's very necessary
for the government to be iterating that
you know you have to maintain social
distancing you have to wear a mask
you know you have to get vaccinated and
um i think the
the issue that's happening right now is
that people are becoming very confident
that they've got the first job so
they're probably you know
safe but but that's not that's not true
you know
so you have we have to be very careful
in terms of like inter uh
city inter state transport thank you
very much and in fact benjamin i've seen
reports that in chile
apparently during the holidays between
december
and february there was quite a bit of
travel
by people between their first and their
second vaccine
when apparently they did not have full
resistance
yet so travel implicated there as well i
gather yeah there was even a holiday
permit where you could go to the beach
and
visit families as well so it's also
that's the contradiction on one side
saying you have to take care but on the
other side it's possible to get this
permit and people who have now
the two vaccines are able even to move
so it's a mobility path and the
scientific world says
what we don't need now is to increase
mobility so that's of course is also
something that should be
discussed about not just traveling in
the country but also
trying to get out of the country in fact
when it comes to mobility the british
government has also been banned for not
for been criticized for not banning
travel from india
as early as needed and we need only look
at the uk
now to see how infectious delta is
the new variant is now almost
exclusively responsible for a surging
infection rate
that prompted authorities to postpone
the long-promised lifting of lockdown
restrictions
and it's causing worry elsewhere as well
[Music]
great britain responded to the delta
covet variant with a massive vaccination
campaign
even though the country has the highest
vaccination rate in europe the delta
variant is spreading throughout the
country like wildfire
the outbreak started in scotland before
spreading all over britain
london was a hot spot the lockdown
reopening in england has been delayed
portugal has turned to more drastic
measures residents of the capital lisbon
are prohibited from leaving the city on
weekends
the police even patrol the exit ramps in
april the country had the lowest
infection rate in europe
the delta variant may have come in via
britain british tourists in portugal
weren't required to quarantine like in
other european countries
and these images are from europe full
beer gardens and packed bars as well as
full stadiums for the euro 2020
championship
is europe heading into the next wave
without a plan
dr kurt what's your answer to that last
question
is the situation in the uk in portugal a
wake-up call
for all of europe should we be doing
things differently
if people believe the pandemic is over
yes there should be a wake-up call that
that
things can can change quickly it is and
remains a dynamic situation
we have to be careful in traveling the
virus itself doesn't travel it needs to
host
humans or animals in this case humans so
if humans travel
we can test we can guarantee we know all
this and we have to implement this and
we'll be extremely careful
to not running into the next wave
nonetheless in your opening statement
you didn't advocate
a new blanket lockdown you said we need
targeted
surveillance in fact at the height of
the second and third
wave it became very difficult for
authorities to track
infection chains there were simply too
many cases has that changed now that
infection rates here at least in germany
are falling
right now that should be possible again
and we should uh try everything to
maintain that level that we can
trace and track and then really know
what's happening but also we need
information about
how likely it is that a person can
spread the virus so there's another
value the ct value for example that we
need to take into account
did that person travel what profession
has that person so that we really
understand the situation rather than
saying
everyone locked down because i think
that's not a good solution we have
learned
better over the last month hopefully
thank you very much and
let me ask benjamin because you of
course
are based here uh in germany and i know
that this new
lockdown in lisbon and the postponement
of lifting of measures
in britain they do have a lot of people
here
worried on the other hand people are
just getting used to this new
normal things seem so so good and
relaxed
do you think that it's going to be very
hard for people here to accept
if new restrictions do in fact have to
be put into place
i think it will be difficult if i
compare the situation in germany with
the situation in chile with this back
and forth so we have to guarantee then
the situation is getting better then you
can move then again you have to stay at
home
so that's why it's so important to have
this crisis communication and go in one
way and say you know
situation will get worse probably in in
in the next month the cases will go up
so it's important to take care now and
there are several tools that we have
where vaccines is only one tool but you
have
um to have tracing of people well
they're traveling now during the euro
cup
germany will face england in wembley of
course and then you have budapest seeing
pictures of a full stadium 100
capacity and then of course it's
important to see which
travel is essential and which travel
could also lead to more cases when
people start moving around and
restrictions are lifted also when it
comes to traveling and quarantining in
the country where you where you're going
to
dr kurt when you see those pictures of
full football
stadiums when you hear that london is
still planning to host the european
championship
final in wembley stadium with 60 000
fans do you think we've all got our
heads in the sand well i hope they're
a test before and after the game
everyone who is
around that statement steady more in the
stadium so obviously that's a quite
risky situation that
people are putting themselves in and and
i hope
that everyone understands that they have
been
exposed potentially and they should be
tested or
placed themselves in carrantine after
and specifically if they have any
symptoms
suggestive of a flu-like symptoms or
like
corona symptoms as many of us should
know now
let me ask ankita because in fact
infection rates in india
now are falling although as you pointed
out uh
at the beginning of the the show india
has vaccinated only a tiny proportion
of its population so far so
what is what is uh accountable for
accountants for
that fall in infection rates and are you
seeing
signs in india of restriction fatigue
um so i'll answer the first question so
obviously like
every pandemic and every wave there's
like a peak and then there's a fall so
that's what happened in india there is a
fall now
uh but we are seeing cases steadily
increasing of the delta plus variant
kerala and maharashtra are
um great examples of what will go wrong
in the future if you know the
governments you know don't [ __ ] up
um i think in terms of uh vaccination
what's
happening is that we had a supply crunch
at the beginning you know uh in march
april may and that was sort of resolved
with like uh
with narendra modi the prime minister
announcing that we will re-centralize
the distribution of vaccines now the
problem is that
in a lot of the people even if they're
getting the first uh
jab they're unable to get the second one
because there's just no supply
so now things have eased up with sputnik
with i think the nova wax vaccine that's
supposed to come um there's covax in
india's indigenous vaccine that's
also there but um what i feel is the
biggest issue right now is the kind of
narratives that go around the vaccine
and there is obviously this big fatigue
where people feel that you know we have
been locked up for too long and you know
we need to stop talking about the
coronavirus and we need to start looking
at the brighter side of life
which is a great way to think but it's
not something that you can implement on
the ground if you like suddenly just
go out and you know um live your life
normally again and now the problem is
that a lot of the offices are opening up
so people are you know going back to
work
so uh now with people going back to work
there's also narratives going around
that india is a poor country we are
economically backward we cannot afford
to sit at home
we have to earn something so these kind
of narratives are sort of like
you know um supporting the ex the
fatigue of the lockdowns
thank you very much and i'll just uh say
to our viewers that uh we're sorry that
uh that uh image of ankita occasionally
is frozen
but i think uh we can all still hear her
well so
that is great uh let us come now to
a deeper look at the vaccination
challenge and
in the race against time between
variants like delta and
vaccines poorer countries suffer a
dramatic disadvantage
despite the mantra that no one is safe
until everyone is safe
the reality is that covid19 dramatically
magnifies global inequality on health
new delhi streets are alive again new
infections
and deaths are decreasing but less than
20 percent
of indian residents have received one
vaccination
nevertheless many of them are still
convinced that they've learned from the
pandemic
[Music]
i don't think people have short memory
but the things got recovered and yeah
it was a very crucial time for everyone
but the thing that people and government
they did a lot
and i think it's fine
in brazil on the other hand the
situation is worsening the country now
has more than 500 000 confirmed corona
deaths
brazilian president bolsonaro downplayed
the dangers of the pandemic for too long
infections are rising in chile as well
even though the government has tried to
stop the virus from spreading with
lockdowns and vaccination campaigns
even worse a new variant has been
discovered in latin american countries
its dangers have not yet been analyzed
do we have to learn to live with the
virus and its variants
benjamin chile is now talking about uh
giving a third booster
shot starting early this fall so quick
two questions to you first of all the
adequacy of the amounts of vaccine you
do have in chilean secondly
do you think that the battle against
kovac could wind up being decided not
here in europe or the u.s but in the
global south
totally i mean if we look at the vaccine
rates of africa for example latin
america what chile really is that
is an exception if you compare it to
other countries we have the kovacs
program we have d7 countries pledging to
donate more vaccines
but that's definitely not enough and
when you look at the situation we just
saw it in brazil what's happening in
bolivia what happened in ecuador also in
all of latin american countries
there is definitely something that that
needs far more support and it's not just
the vaccines but also the financial
support
for the people for them to stay at home
because that's important to note as well
not everyone
breaches the rules because they want to
there are some of them of course who go
out who have illegal parties
but others who have to go out with
quarantine is not an option i mean
that's
a privilege during this pandemic thank
you dr court
grand promises were made during the g7
meeting about
how much vaccine the north wants to send
to the global south but when you look at
the
actual numbers i think it's 55 million
doses that the u.s has now pledged
additionally
it's a tiny drop in the bucket
this is essentially a situation of
triage
something doctors are very familiar with
where we have
scarce resources and we have to decide
where they are best
used given the magnitude of the problem
what would you say
when you look at this health inequality
and the very low numbers of people being
vaccinated in poorer countries
is that where we need to be sending
vaccine right now rather than keeping it
here for ourselves in
in the rich north it's very unfortunate
that the g7 and others speak about the
importance of global health but then
one of the biggest crises on global
health that the action is is very very
limited and so yes we have to understand
it's a global pandemic
and if we do not prevent the globe
pretty much from spreading the virus
then the virus will come back
so like the decision to my country first
of those who can afford it and then
sending a little bit of vaccine to other
countries is not sufficient we have to
substantially
increase the efforts and send vaccine to
these countries
and ideally build up production
capacities in this region so they can
actually produce their own vaccines
let me go back to ankita because of
course that was a big topic for us
last time we talked on this program the
idea
had been put out there that we need to
see a lifting of patent restrictions so
that
countries in the global south can make
more of their own vaccine but in fact
india has the production capacity it has
the skills and know-how
the problem there was bottlenecks on
resources
so are you any more uh amenable to those
arguments about lifting patent
restrictions then you were
back last time we spoke
yes they should be the restrictions
should be removed
because uh right now what we need to
understand is we don't have much
research on
whether you know the indigenous indian
vaccine which is coaxing
with it can whether it can you know uh
prevent uh you know
uh deaths or you know hospitalizations
if you get the delta variant
we only have research on pfizer and
astrazeneca
vaccines which are you know which can
prevent death if you have
two doses of the vaccine so it is
essential that we have
uh we remove the pattern restrictions on
the vaccines that work
and we can produce them in india because
the issue is that uh
if you uh if you try to bring something
like pfizer
uh in a country like india which doesn't
have that much cold storage
how are you going to store it so you
know if you remove the restriction india
can produce it according to its own
convenience and you know in its own way
and i think that should be the case for
most countries especially
you know continents like africa where
you know uh the populations can't even
get vaccinated before
the 2023 or 2024. thank you
let me pose one question with the
request for
a one-word answer to dr kurt and
benjamin given where we are today must
we acknowledge
corona isn't going away and that it is
time to simply focus
our efforts on living with it and
perhaps trying to mitigate its deadlines
dr kurt we are
already living with so many viruses and
we will live in the future with corona
benjamin there's so many tools now we
have to use them
thank you very much and thanks to all of
you for joining us for to the point
hope to see you soon
you